you
[Music]
good afternoon today it's my great
pleasure to introduce professor Wayne
Luke Wayne is a professor of computer
engineering at the Imperial College
London is research covers the
development of hardware and software
capabilities to address demanding
applications such as genomic data
processing and climate modeling he's a
fellow the Royal Academy of Engineering
and VI Tripoli and VCS so with that
Wayne please
and you very much can for that very
generous introduction I am extremely
pleased to have the opportunity to give
this talk this I think is probably my
second time
and I hope I'm not saying the same thing
as what I did maybe five or ten years
ago whatever I came last time and I very
much thank can to take a timeout that
despite all the hustle and effort
running the ASAP conference he still
managed to arrange for this visit which
I'm extremely grateful so so this is a
talk about how to exploit reconfigurable
technology to accelerate genomic data
processing much of the work has actually
been done by my PhD student James Aaron
and and there are also other
collaborators as well which I will
explain in a minute but just in case you
haven't been to Imperial College this is
a photograph of the main campus of
Imperial College
so I'm based in the Department of
computing which is over there and I work
very closely with my colleagues in the
Department of Electrical and Electronic
Engineering which is this tall building
around there and and there are
well-known landmarks such as the Natural
History Museum or if you don't want to
look at dinosaurs then have a look at
the Babbage early computing machine in
the Science Museum or we might just want
to go around in the Kensington Gardens
or the high part around that and an
imperial college is easy to recognize
because it has this power which is
called like so many things in England
named after the Queen so this is called
the Queen's tower so next time when you
have a chance to fly into London my
suggestion is to try to sit on the right
hand side because I took this picture
from the plane you can see part of the
wing over here so but left hand is ready
to be boring so see on the right hand
side so just have a quick description of
our research team at Imperial College so
we have quite a diverse range of
research interests covering from
applications to design techniques and
tools for systems that can be customized
okay so obviously software can be
customized but because we also target
reconfigurable technology therefore
quite a bit of the hardware can also be
customized as well and that really makes
that this research so exciting so our
focus is on improving the efficiency of
the design so how to develop
customization to make the implementation
more effective and efficient and then at
the same time how to improve the
productivity of the designers okay now
and designers could be at different
levels from application builders to
design to developers to library
developers to platform and
infrastructure development and and so on
and I'll work actually covered both
high-performance computing as well as
embedded systems which I'll give some
examples in a minute so our team
actually spent two departments I lead
the team in computing department and we
have around six Research Associates so
these are typically postdoctoral
researchers and around 10 PhD students
in various stages of completion and then
we have somewhere between 3 to 6 MSC
students and graduate students depending
on a particular year so we also have
about 2 to 3 visiting students from
different universities around the world
and we love to collaborate with them and
and over in the Department of Electrical
and Electronic Engineering there are
another 30 to 40 researchers so together
we actually have quite a big team and
and we cover both theoretical foundation
as well as practical applications and
indeed I think is really that coverage
that interaction between foundational
and practical concerns that makes this
feel so exciting so we have as I already
mentioned collaboration with many
universities like Cambridge Oxford food
done in China and Princeton and Stanford
in the United States and also Sydney in
Australia and we also have a lot of
industrial collaborators and Microsoft
is actually one of them I'm delighted to
say so we have various projects the fp7
these are the European Union projects so
these are the project acronyms
and when if I have time I could describe
some of these in a bit more detail the
one we are running right now involving
European colleagues is one based on the
horizon 2020 framework and the acronym
for the projects called extra and it is
actually looking at how to exploit
reconfigurable technology for excess
scale capability in the future and then
EPS LC is the UK grant agency so that
correspond to the National Science
Foundation in the US and we have various
kinds of projects supported by them as
well so just to give a few examples
about the type of applications that we
look at so for example we study climate
modeling and and some of these
applications we could get more than 10
times faster for genomics I'll describe
a bit more later on we also have done
quite a bit of research on accelerating
financial modelling and then we also
have some work on avionics monitoring
which I'll describe a little bit more in
a minute
so some recent advances is we are just
beginning to start a new project
sponsored by Intel on looking at
accelerators for cloud computing in
particular how to manage visualizations
and elastic resources and so on
and applications could involve genomics
and also finance and we also have
research on automating the development
of the science that can
reconfigure at runtime in order to
improve the performance or improve the
energy efficiency and and and that is
one of the European project the project
extra that I mentioned briefly before
and one of these mechanism for
automation is to eliminate idle
resources again if you are interested
let me know because we already have some
publications we also are interested in
looking at new FPGA fabric so again as
part of the European project that we
studied a new way of enhancing the
February so that we could optimize
dynamic data access for applications
such as memcache sparse matrix vector
computation sorting and and so on and
then hardly surprising that we also have
quite quite a bit of effort on machine
learning and indeed the interaction
between machine learning and
reconfigurable design and that piece of
work involves a UK company comic seller
and and and here we look at how well
what both of the current effort has been
on how to make use of reconfigurable
technology FPGAs and so on to accelerate
machine learning but in addition we also
interested in using machine learning
ideas to improve or to optimize
reconfigurable design as well so I think
they are interesting interaction between
these two areas and then last but not
least that we also have projects
involving Airbus that did four designs
that could be self adaptive in order to
develop new generation
of avionics instruments so that they
have better monitoring about their own
behavior so that if something goes wrong
then the instrument would know that well
don't believe this reading because
perhaps something is not right so we
include the monitoring support
facilities in a circuit itself so this
is actually become part of the hardware
and we could monitor not just the
performance or functional properties but
also monitor the temporal as well as
statistical properties and so on like
looking at the mean and variance of
various output samples now in the longer
term what we hope to do is to understand
the principles of compiling from a
high-level description which could be
domain-specific so it could be MATLAB or
Java or whatever the appropriate higher
level description and how it could be
optimized by what I just put there is a
compiler but it could be multiple stages
of optimization and generate code for
both six processes so if this could be
the usual conventional processes as well
as customizable processes such as FPGA
and so on
and increasingly we are not just looking
at what looks like a top-down flow but
also a bottom-up flow as well so it
really is an interaction between the
compilation of the top-down but also
analyzing the compiled code and some of
that could be at runtime as well so that
the results could be feedback to the
compiler or to the runtime system in
order to provide not just more optimized
implementation but also more secure
and more robust implementations so in
case there might be false or other
issues at runtime okay but that would be
a long-term effort and that we hope to
achieve in the future okay so I'll just
going to spend a few minutes describing
the background of the topic of today
which is genomic data processing so this
is quite a well-known figure that you
might have seen before but the
sequencing of genome genomic data
started quite a while ago with Frederick
Sanger and and and that is where he got
the Nobel Prize many years ago but but a
lot of that work has been menu and even
the initial machines are not very
producing a lot of information so it's
only in the more recent time and I'll
show you the timeline in the next slide
but what's now known as the next
generation sequencing that these sort of
machines can really produce a
significant amount of information of the
genome and that really revolutionize the
the healthcare area and if we have a
look at the timeline one could see that
I guess the interesting comparison is
with the well-known Moore's Law and as
we all know that in computing but when
we have the older technology
then then you'll see that the increase
in information you can see the
comparative Moore's Law the slope is not
as steep okay and then is around 2004
2005 time at that time that new
generation sequencing capability has
come into play and then you can see that
suddenly the slope become a lot more
steeper okay and the interesting thing
is that if we compare that with Moore's
Law the old technology is not increasing
as quick as Moore's law and therefore
that hasn't been a big problem for
storing the genomic information ever now
since the genomic capability the
processing is producing so much
information than what where is Moore's
Law is increasing at a lower rate if you
talk to genomics researchers a lot of
them are saying that they need to spend
and increasing among of money to just
buying storage to store what they
process okay so that is actually one of
the motivation of our compression work
than how explain in a minute okay so so
the two major challenges are first how
to efficiently analyze the genomics data
okay and a lot of the auto necks are
actually in the actual genomics pipeline
and I'll explain one of those in a
minute and then the second challenge is
how to efficiently store the data so
again there are obviously existing
general purpose method like g-sib that
many have used before but those general
premise techniques may not be the most
effective
and I'll explain that in a minute so so
so how do we apply this compression
capability and indeed there is this
method called reference based
compression so that we compress the
genome with a reference genome so that
because one has found that the
differences between different genomes
are very small okay
because genomes themselves are very
large so although there might be lots of
differences but in the whole picture is
actually very small so the idea is one
could find where the differences are and
then just compress the differences
alright so this is pretty obvious if you
do that then we could have very high
compression ratio but it is quite slow
okay so how can we speed it up while
retaining the high compression ratio so
that that is the challenge okay so the
technology we use is called FPGA super
mobile gate arrays and in particular the
system that I'll describe today is based
on a UK company called maxilla so they
call it a maxilla
data flow engine and the basic
computational element is an ell
terrorist at X 5 FPGA and also the card
has a 48 gigabyte of DRN okay and later
on we'll compare the performance of that
with Intel CPUs and also NVIDIA GPUs ok
so we are computer engineer so we really
don't know very much about genomics so
it is our great fortune that we are able
to collaborate with some of the best
researchers in the world on genomics and
they are professor Dennis Lo and put the
roasted Chu at the chinese university of
hong kong and and they
they were actually provide the
foundation of a lot of the advances that
I'm going to describe so they stun the
basic scientific underpinning that that
could support a non-invasive prenatal
kenzan transplantation assessment I'll
explain a little bit of that in a minute
okay and then we also work closely with
Professor gel in the same group and he
has developed a particular genomic data
processing pipeline called the metal
pipe that we map and accelerate using
FPGA okay so this is diagram that I
borrow from professor Lowe's paper and
the technology is very much based on
this idea of what is known in genomic
perms called methylation okay and to
give the simplest possible explanation
by looking at the plasma in the blood
one can actually find information by
genomic sequencing of the whole genome
so that we obtain information of the
healthiness of the different organs in
the human body okay so the exciting
thing is that this would provide
information not for just one particular
organ but it could quite information
about the liver the lymphocytes the
presenter and so on okay so in other
words by analyzing the information in
the blood plasma and by this whole
genome sequencing one could provide
technique one could predict the the
healthiness of fetus and/or unborn
babies for example that would be for
prenatal testing okay but the exciting
thing is that the procedure can be used
not just for prenatal testing although
if you only do prenatal testing that's
already a amazing advance but it's not
limited to that the same procedure could
be used for detecting and monitoring
cancer could be used to monitor organ
transplantation and and and so on okay
so this is a amazing technique and and
the interesting thing is one of the
bottleneck is actually in the sequencing
and that's bit that we try to generate
but but just to provide a few for the
practicality of these methods that
around two years ago that the BBC News
explained that is around 1 in every 200
women might lose her baby after a
particular situation because when we do
the prenatal testing it used to be
invasive so so when when some of the
fluid is being extracted that might
actually have hurt or effects on both
the mother and her baby so the technique
that I just described before is
non-invasive because all you need to do
is just to do a blood test okay so one
could extract the blood plasma and and
do do not a analysis on the blood plasma
in order to find out whether there are
genetic analysis of the baby so so we
found that the number of invasive tests
can be
Jews by more than 80% okay so and
therefore the the risk of damaging the
mother and the baby would be
significantly reduce and then just last
week that that other piece of news that
the UK Health Authority the National
Health Service NHS the the chief medical
officer in the UK said that increasingly
these sort of genomic techniques should
be applied to a fourth example
monitoring and testing whether patients
might might might be might likely to
have cancer for example so instead of
just waiting and so the symptoms become
severe if there is the easy way by just
doing the blood testing one could
actually monitor whether there are
possibilities that one might get cancer
one might be able to protect the
population much better but also at a
lower cost because we try to prevent
that rather than try to cure it okay so
so this sort of techniques should become
increasingly important so the that sort
of information would be obtained by this
spiral phonetics pipeline and this is a
technique developed by Professor John
and and that involves this capability
called the whole genome bisulfite
sequencing and again I won't go into
details but if try to align the genomic
information the genome from a patient
with a reference genome which is known
to be healthy okay
and and I'll show it in a minute to give
you a few for what that process is like
okay so part of date is called a short
wit mapping because the genomics machine
breakdown the patient's genome into
small pieces so is somewhere between 50
to 100 characters and we need to match
that against a three billion character
of a human genome okay so this is the
reference genome which should be from a
healthy person and then these are the
fragments of the genome from the patient
and and and we try to check what are the
differences between the patient's genome
and and the reference genome okay now
when there are differences it might not
always be a real difference so for
example you could imagine in this case
we we sort of we match that against that
and we say well that should be an A in
here but it's a G right now but because
there are other fragments that we check
to show that it could be an A as well
now that could be an opera note so
therefore this is likely to be an error
of the sequencing machine rather than a
real difference example okay so now in
another case when all the short reads
chakras fragments all have the same
character which is different from the
reference genome then there is a high
probability that the patient's genome is
really different from the reference
genome okay so that shows that it's
likely that this
a genetic diversity now in some cases it
might not matter too much but in other
cases that could be related to some
recognized diseases genetic diseases
that that one one need to be aware of
okay so now a lot of existing software
to success so some of them are called
bowtie sub 3 and so on but but because
the the genetic machine and so on they
could do so much information all these
short reads and so on so it would be 300
million or even more then it often takes
hours to a process even or the most
powerful machines okay so what we aim to
do is to accelerate this alignment of
this chakra statements against the
reference genome so for example in
professor lowe's university that they
have one of the most powerful machines
it could take more than five hours on a
24-fret see own system and so on so what
we hope to do is actually to overhaul
overcome drawback of previous
accelerators so for example they might
not have the same functionality as the
software version and then some of them
now they must the function but then they
may not have the accuracy they might not
provide the same result compared with
the software okay so what we hope to do
is not only provide the speed but also
make sure that the result the
functionality would be almost identical
as the software version okay
so again something that we do which is
slightly different is that a lot of
existing work is based on a well-known
technique called smith-waterman method
but we found this before the method has
some drawback which I'll explain a bit
later later on so we make use of a
particular data structure called FM
index which is essentially a compressive
string index that allows to very quickly
search for substring in a big string and
that this particular index is
constructed by a technique called the
burrows-wheeler transform now again if
you haven't come across that do not
worry because you could just do a
Wikipedia and then quickly explain to
you what what it does now there are
various parameters required so for
example we do short width of up to 200
base pairs and an hour work right now
allows up to two mismatches but but we
could actually support as many as one
light and then we also extended this FM
index technique which was a exact match
technique to support a possible
alignment as well so we could do search
from both ends so we got by directional
search and we could also use
backtracking to test all the possible
permutations that that could happen okay
so you know accelerator we developed
modules which could do exact match and
then we also develop modules that could
do either matching with one mismatch or
or two mismatches and and so on okay and
then what we do and again that is
something that we learn from our
genomics research colleagues but most of
the matches example up to 60 to 80
percent would actually be exact match
okay so you could imagine what we'll do
is we will scream
the short reads through these different
elements and then for those which
already have match then exact match then
then then we don't need to pass them to
do the approximate match and so on so
the amount of a match short reads from
here could be very small and and that
could be one way of making things faster
so in addition we also make various
optimizations such as make sure that the
FM index structure is optimized to make
sure that we could saturate the memory
bandwidth okay so the only thing that
stopped us from running faster is the
memory speed okay so if you have faster
memory then we could actually want this
even faster and we also have various
optimizations to reduce the access to
the DRAM
because we did the big theorem on the
board in order to store the reference
genome and then other possibility is
actually to exploit runtime
configuration because what we can do is
that in the beginning we could configure
the we could home we could find
configured the whole chip to just to the
exact matching because the exact match
modules are relatively small so we could
put more on them and we could increase
the parallelism as much as we can as
long as we could support the memory
bandwidth and then later on when we have
done all the accept matches and we could
reconfigure the chip to do the
approximate match for for one element
and also and then for two mismatches and
so on so these approximate match modules
are typically a bit bigger and a bit
more time but because
there are fewer sequences that we need
to do the our process matching and
therefore it doesn't matter that that
they are their bit bigger okay so the
difference is if we do a Miss Waterman
they use the same module for both exact
match and approximate match okay but
that means that potentially the number
of bottom end modules that you could put
on an FPGA would be smaller right
because the exact match Bourdieu is
smaller than the approximate match
enemies okay so by pointing that
information that there are more exact
matches and approximate matches we could
actually organize our data flow in in
order to accelerate the computation even
more okay so the evaluation as I
mentioned is based on a system from
Excel ER and the comparison rgt you some
Nvidia and CPU from Intel and some
examples are from this public domain
genomics database and from our
colleagues in genomics they said they
are happy to find up to two mismatches
and we could locate all the hits and and
in a particular format and so on and
these are some of the numbers that we
get that right now our hardware
accelerated version is up to five times
faster then bowtie - which is one of the
software version on the CPU and and also
it is up to 420 a half times faster than
the GPU on that and more importantly we
actually achieve the same accuracy
compared to the software version okay
and indeed we found that right now the
the reporter speed that I show here I
actually limited
the i/o file IO so if we could do that
faster then we could actually spin up
the whole thing even more and then of
course the FPGA version is over five
times more energy efficient and the
software version okay and what I'll do
in the next two minutes is to describe
how we could in addition also apply
acceleration to accelerate the
compression of genomics data okay and
this method is based on a reference
oriented technique so for example we are
compressing this data okay remove these
are the short leaf fragments against a
reference genome like that okay so for
example for this particular sequence the
compressed version looks like this when
where the first number corresponds to
where the match occurs so you can see
that is a a PGG so this is it matches
the five the first five character in the
reference genome okay so it start from
the position zero because it's part on
the first one and there are five
characters that match so that is five
now and then the first one that better
match we put it at the last element here
okay so the first one is a that doesn't
match the reference genome and then we
could use the same idea for example to
compress this particular segment into
these two triples and and and so on okay
so so this task actually turns out to be
pretty similar to the sequence alignment
and we actually use the same hardware in
order to accelerate that and and we
could compare that again some of the
software method that I mention in a
minute okay so there are actually two
well-known formats one is called faster
the other one is called fast Q so the
faster format our federated version is
called faster sip and this the faster
former correspond to pre-assemble
genomes which already mostly in order
and so on and we could merge the
adjacent ones to improve compression
ratio even more fast queue is another
format and is sequence data from either
strand of the DNA and and we could
actually also map the reverse complement
to again these are some techniques that
is well known but if you're interested
we could get back to that later on okay
so the overall organization of the
computation is light like this and there
in the file format for this genomic
sequence they're all these identifiers
and and so on which we would just
compress using software and then the
actual content of the sequences and so
turning this sequence later into the
free to pose that I showed before that
part is being accelerated using the
hardware that I showed before and then
the result of that can be further
compressed in order to find the the
final result that I shown here okay so
what I show before is the fastest it so
this is the FASTA format the fast q form
it is roughly the same except that they
have in addition to the identify the
also have strand information they have
quality scores and so on these are all
compressed by software separately and
right now we are just compressing the
actual sequence data over there
okay so again these are just the
hardware system and a software system
that we use you know evaluation and the
FASTA format we we use the actual human
genome data using human genome bill 38
so there are different bills and then
for the fast queue format and we use a
different set of public data okay so
this is this table describes the results
of accelerating the faster computation
and and essentially that one could get
speed-up of up to 12 times of the best
of the software version and then the
compression time so a compression ratio
could be proved 12 times more and and
the compression time is comparable to to
the best as well and then for the
compression time of the accelerated
version for the fastest it it is right
now is to 2 times the suite of software
version but but that's because it is
limited by the pharma oh so we hope that
we have the next generation of system
that would allow us to overcome that and
then for the fast kill format that the
conversion ratio could be similar to the
software version but then conversion
time could be more than 20 times faster
okay and and then again somebody
hardware version is limited by the file
IO right now somewhere compression time
is less but then we still have high
compression ratio of some of the best
software compression techniques okay so
this method has potential of not just
accelerating the speed but also it could
actually give better compression results
as well okay okay so right now there are
a number of possibilities for further
improvement like we are working with the
Francis Crick Institute which the new
genomics Institute in London which allow
which which we will put our hardware
design two different kinds of hybrid
platforms in order to get hopefully
better results we were also testing out
this run on more data sets and also we
are interested in accelerating other
stages of genomics pipeline because
right now our focus is really on this
particular part in the middle which
involve alignment and discovering
variation in the genomic sequences there
are other parts of the genomics pipeline
for example how to do functional
predictions how to do for example RNA
sequencing and so on which we are not
doing right now but we think a lot of
the technique that we are looking at can
also be applied to that so that we hope
would become future work and then in
addition we also hope to automate the
production of these optimized pipelines
so that they could become useful both
for scientific research to discovered
genomic diseases or cure of those and
and also we hope that the acceleration
would also benefit health care and
clinical applications so that in new
generation of hospital machines that
could benefit from techniques that we
describe here so that we could have
better compression
at a high speed and so on okay so thank
you very much could you go back to slide
I'm pretty sure
so is there any could you give it a
little bit of some intuition as to why
the compression ratio is so much higher
for the hardware communication okay the
some of the software goes for
general-purpose compression okay so
those are not reference base okay
I mean so those are essentially
variations of sip or gzip and so on so
they could compress sort of everything
but in terms of the genome they don't
exploit the specific structure of the
genome whereas in the reference base
compression as I mentioned is we know
there is a reference that we compare
again so that we only need to basically
find out what the differences are and
then compress the difference same
algorithm whatever you're running in
hardware and software that's what we
also do the for example we've one is in
software it's what we did is our own
version in software okay we - it's in
hardware
ok sorry that I did make it clear in
here but yeah
ok so so so that shows that our you will
see the compression ratio of these
software and having either say yeah and
the hardware is slightly faster but but
we think that there are still scopes for
improving the speed of the hardware
because right now is the file i/o
because they're storing in a distance so
on we spend most of time taking the
thing
from disk so if we have much faster i/o
and so on or put it in the cache or
whatever then that ought to be a lot
faster machine how much I wish you ran
the hardware bought has 48 gigabytes of
vram software I I think is tons like
creating sufficiently obvious file its
margin for you
oh no they've 48 is storing the
reference genome right but but the
patient they got 300 million right you
know so we will need to get the the data
to be to be match externally so so the
DRM only contain the reference which we
shall match against because the on chip
Ram is not big enough to store the even
the reference genome you see for just
just to make it absolutely clear that
that it is the so be for the genomic
data format containing the headers and
strength or nation and quality score and
so on so we are only accelerating the
actual sequence data right now in
principle we probably could also
separate these other bits as well but
but they are not a state so right now we
sort of the anon accelerator but but in
principle we probably could have
accelerate everything if all the
bandwidth and all that could support
that
oh we are we are evaluating them with
the UK national health service and all
that so I imagine when we are sure that
everything we are doing is appropriate
we'll find a way to make sure it will
benefit the whole world it's all part of
keep it secret
okay so yeah so I think eventually we
would that we hope to put in the public
domain or whatever is the appropriate
way to benefit I mean it's such an
important area right so why do you
mention that in like 30 months
organizations of genomics of different
thing has already been done by the NHS
and the building supplies so is that
public like can someone go and like oh I
think that is a piece of news I got from
a new specified okay so so I think
patient data are extremely sensitive so
I think I think you need to assign so
many piece of paper and you probably
could only do work inside that secure
database or something like that no
injustice like this room of the
patient's needs and English yes I think
I think there are possibilities and
indeed right now there are also some
sort of real public domain information
but but I think some of the existing
sort of large patient database seem to
have various restrictions and I think
they will allow scientific research to
access that but but there are all sorts
of restrictions and and and so on you
know and in fact I think very recently
there's the case or in a newspaper that
google deepmind was in the news because
I think one of the hospitals or somebody
who has a
patient information sort of provide that
data to them for testing the algorithms
but then it was sort of being challenged
legally that that is not completely
properly and so on so I think this is an
area that we learn to be very careful
offline yeah okay great thank you very
much thank you